be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay so getting into powers of X part
five like we are getting to a point
where the series is wrapping up the
series is coming to an end and uh I am
very much excited about this because I'm
really curious to see not even because
I'm not really excited because it's
ending I'm excited because I want to
know where it goes next right I mean I'm
kind of sad it's ending to be honest
because like it's been an amazing story
so far ah but what this does is it
initially picks up with Forge now here's
the thing here's the funny thing I feel
like only the most steadfast and
staunchest of x-men fans would know this
but Jonathan Hickman is not pulling this
out of nowhere and here's the cool thing
so initially Charles Xavier meets with
Forge to basically up upgrade cerebro
this is where the reasons why Hickman
writing is so good is because it ties
into everything right so if you come
into this and you haven't really read
the x-men or you're not really familiar
with the x-men the idea is okay cool so
somewhere along the lines like Xavier
asked for words to basically upgrade
cerebro and like Miss cerebro was
originally made by Xavier so like
Hickman's changing the past no that's
not true um if you go back and you read
x-men vol 2 issue number 5 but there's a
point where where Xavier approaches
Forge and basically says you're a mutant
with the ability to basically be Tony
Stark more or less right like that's his
power right his power is that he know he
can basically understand machinery and
how it works in all that kind of cool
stuff that's why I like forge is
basically the x-men's version of Tony
Stark the difference is that Forge
losses if he lost his powers he'd be no
more capable of understanding machinery
then you know you were me like complex
machinery then like you were me right I
mean we can't build an Iron Man suit ah
but the fact remains that that during
that second run of x-men like x-men vol
2 basically wound up happening is in the
aftermath of everything that happened
with the Phoenix saga the Dark Phoenix
saga and all that kind of stuff that
Xavier basically approached Forge and
asked him to upgrade cerebro using Shiar
technology and so what this shows is
basically how we got to that point right
like where Xavier basically walks up on
on on Forge and says I need you to show
me how it is that you you know like I
need you to upgrade cerebro with Shiar
technology and the reason why is
actually a little bit different here so
beforehand it was simply just like the
system needs to be upgraded right like
we to have a more like we need to have a
better reach and a stronger
understanding of everything but
beforehand it was it was away from all
to basically kind of bring the x-men
into like the modern age of storytelling
essentially and really kind of operating
everything across the board the reason
why it's actually happening here is
because with what what it is at Xavier
wants to do
cerebro simply not powerful enough but
when it comes to the Shiar technology
that's out there
it definitely is that Xavier essentially
wants to have a system of redundancy
right he wants to have a system to where
he can copy the minds of all the mutants
in existence now we know that from the
last house of X video but the question
was how do we get to that point and how
does it work and how can it last for the
long term and that's what ford says
forges like wolf what you're asking here
is not something as simple as I want to
copy the minds of all beings in
existence it's a lot more nuanced than
that like one you need to be able to
basically have an unlimited amount of
storage right because what you're
talking about doing is backing up the
minds of an individual person and then
in turn having to back it up on a
regular basis right because what happens
if you backup the mind of someone and
then they turn evil and then they die
but you want to bring them back if the
only version that you have is the most
recent one which was their evil version
you're gonna bring back the evil version
of themselves instead you want to go
back to like back in the day you could
pick which version of themselves that
you want to bring back in this new body
that you would essentially be creating
for them and so if you do that like
you're gonna need a vast amount of
storage because you're talking about
mapping and storing the human psyche
which is anybody will tell you it takes
a little bit more than a thumb drive and
then from there you're talking about
having a system of redundancy meaning
that you're gonna have to have multiple
backups so that you don't have to worry
about if one of them goes down or gets
destroyed that you've lost all your data
so what you're talking about is an
unlimited amount of information stored
on an unlimited amount of storage like
how in the world do you expect to pull
this often nothing on earth exists like
that and that's what Xavier says yes but
the Shiar dart really like there way
beyond humanity in terms of technology
like they can store an unlimited amounts
of information and basically keep their
technology going on forever hence the
reason why they're an entire galactic
spanning civilization this conquered
multiple civilizations and forced them
all to worship them so it's basically
like I want five backups for this whole
system it's cool and it's really
interesting to see this exchange between
the two because ultimately Xavier ends
up asking like you're the only real
mutant on our side that I can trust with
this like are you going to be able to
make this work are you gonna be able to
pull this off and ultimately of course
as we know from from x-men history Forge
says yes now here's the important thing
to bear in mind it could be that that
Xavier I'm sorry they're the higgling
comes back and changes that that's one
thing to always bear in mind when it
comes to what it is that Hickman is
doing just because things were a certain
way doesn't mean they will be that way
now right I mean the guy is basically
reworking rebooting the x-men for uh for
really the modern age he could change
anything at any point in time so take it
with a grain of salt it's not an
absolute
an absolute you know form and function
and structure or anything like that now
from this point this is this is why I
love Hickman world-building right
because imagine this but unlike a much
grander scale and that's basically how
Hickman writes long-form stories right
so like three four five year runs on the
X bin or the Fantastic Four or the
Avengers and New Avengers as basically
how this works and so if you recall one
of the ways in which kokoa was able to
operate as a nation as a nation-state
and generate income was by using the
various leaves of Pecola the various
plant life that was there to synthesize
drugs they could do things like like
extend human life by five years or cure
all militant mental illnesses and
different things like that now something
else that that that's really intriguing
is the way he shines a light on xavier
here because xavier basically travels to
the louvre alongside magneto and usually
you know uses his telepathic powers
forces everybody to leave and then meets
with emma frost
and remember this is kind of a cool
concept because the way it seems to be
going right now emma frost still has
dealings with the Hellfire Club right so
she's kind of on again off again with
the x-men it's not where she was doing
like Grant Morrison's run where she's
like a full-on member of the x-men she's
kind of out doing her own thing at the
moment now a lot of this probably comes
out of x-men vs. Inhumans and the fact
that what she had done had basically
been revealed but Hickman hasn't really
tied into that so there's no reason to
believe that's the absolute case but the
fact remains that what is up happening
is Xavier basically tells her like
you're aware of the fact that gurko is
basically creating medicines out there
that can essentially shut down and
really ruin the entire pharmaceutical
industry and the rest of the world like
you're aware that that's what we're
doing right like we're basically pumping
out various medicines and cures that the
pharmaceutical company doesn't really
seem to be interested in doing because
they're putting money they're putting
profits over progression and so because
of that like we basically stepped in
where they failed and we've essentially
dominated the market now and and we've
we've shut off pretty much every at
every access point where anybody could
topple us right like we own the means of
production we keep the means of
production secret no one gets in or out
of cacoa
unless they let them so it's not like
humanity could send in a spy some of the
pharmaceutical industry could send in a
spy and get all this information on how
to duplicate these drugs in an intern
send him out there because even then
they would need krakoa to make them so
any drug they created would be a
half-measure
humanity would sniff it out fast they
would turn on it and it would go back to
using the drugs that are coming out of
kokoa the various medicines coming out
of there and so it's like we've
essentially dominated and courted this
corner this market in its entirety what
we need is the means to be able to get
into countries that have a mutant
population and countries that
rejected our offer and this is what sone
is so really nefarious about what it is
that Xavier is doing because what he
basically tell her tells Emma Frost is I
need you to get back into contact with
Sebastian Shaw I need you to rejoin the
Hellfire Club and it's just kind of like
wow because it's like you will be the
front face operation right you'll get
50% like I'm sorry you'll get a 50-year
contract with a more than fair share of
money that's generated here and then in
turn
she'll be the public face should be the
marketing face right she'll be the one
you see on TV and the commercials and on
and on frost you want to live five more
years well then take this drug from
Tekoa you know are different things like
that
you know what'll really go on is with
the black King with with Sebastian Shaw
because of the fact that he is by all
intents and purposes a criminal he's a
bad guy but he still has a lot of
contacts and a lot of reach due to the
fact that the Hellfire Club really
immerse itself in what was essentially
world domination albeit behind the
scenes that what Sebastian Shaw can do
is get their drugs into into these
countries that have rejected the offers
of kirkuk by using like black book
operations and then in turn get mutants
out and get the drugs in it's a pretty
nefarious plan because what it basically
means is flooding countries with the
croco and drugs and it's pretty sinister
like it's pretty dark xavier is becoming
like a drug kingpin now is essentially
what it is now it's interesting because
xavier masks it behind the perception of
well it's all in the effort of getting
mutants out and basically getting them
back home to krakoa but it but it seems
it even then it's pretty dark and this
is this is actually really cool I dig
this because what it shows is it Xavier
is willing to do whatever needs to be
done in order to get his mutants back
home right I mean that's one of the
things we've talked about recently the
people who win the wars are the ones
that do it needs to be done to win the
war not the guy trying to change the
hearts and minds that isn't work but it
is it's cool it works really effectively
because at the end of the day Emma Frost
basically says yes I'll side with you on
this I'll help you make this happen we
will find a way to pull this off and
that's why it's so awesome here that's
why you see this this really cool
concept because what they also do is
they say we want to bring you on we want
to give you two seats on the client
council of Kirk Cola basically a Council
of 12 bits leading the Kirk Owen mutant
population basically the entirety de
mutant population all going to be led by
by a Council of the twelve Magneto
Professor X of course with a being named
after the after the seasons Magneto
Professor X are going to be you know two
of the three we don't know the other
ones and then we know that Sebastian
Shaw and Emma Frost are going to take to
spy
and then Emma Frost is asking for third
we have no idea who that one's gonna go
to you if you also who went to hell you
if they brought him back but nonetheless
at this point it basically is is kind of
like this telepathic message sent out to
Xavier which gives us the reason why all
these mutants appeared on cacoa in the
last issue it's basically saying like we
are working on a thing like Ricola will
become your home if you choose to accept
it if you want to be here you'll be safe
from all prying eyes you'll be safe from
from all forms of humanity's oppression
this will be a safe space for you notice
here that what what Xavier is basically
doing here is Avalon right Avalon
Providence whatever you want to call it
you know from Magneto's history when he
created like asteroid him and basically
brought all the mutants or as many
mutants would leave Earth Xavier
approached him at that point on it was
like that's a terrible idea
we have to have the peaceful coexistence
between it between humans and mutants
what Xavier seems to have recently done
and are done in recent years is
understand that like sometimes you can't
change the hearts and minds of people
and he never should have tried in the
first place the way you should have done
was just that hey look if that's how you
want it to be that's fine then we'll all
just go over here but understand like
let me make this clear and no uncertain
terms
you stay away we stay away if you come
over to where we're at then we're gonna
worry we're gonna bring everything you
know and love to ruin right well
everything that you know and love burns
down around you in ash you're gonna have
to look and accept the fact you did this
to yourself at the end of the day it's
basically keeping all the mutant
population safeguarded by whatever means
necessary now a funny thing that kind of
goes on here this is why I love the way
that Jonathan Hickman writes a name with
a submariner name of the Submariner gets
a message of course from from Xavier
because name was a mutant and so as a
result of that name or of course being a
proud king you know the king of Atlantis
is told by Xavier why in the world would
I accept your offer you want to play
King and that's cute and that's fine but
boy I've been a king for eons like I've
been a king for a long time so while
it's nice that you want to do this you
hardly know what it means so you don't
really understand what you're asking you
don't know what you're creating you're
just doing a thing where as I understand
what it really means to be a king so if
you want to give me your offer that's
fine but come back when you're serious
come back when you actually mean it and
you actually know what you're talking
about dude I love Namor I love the way
that Hickman writes name work because
he's so arrogant and so haughty it's so
awesome just seen Namor written in such
a really cool way but again jumping
1,000 years in the future in the last
few issues or so we had basically talked
about how this new elevated form of what
was i should say kind of a combination
of humanity and machinery had basic
moved in the direction of wanting to be
absorbed by the Phalanx right it kind of
becoming part of this universal
consciousness so basically going out and
becoming something greater you know a
higher state of enlightenment or entropy
or whatever it is you like it was a cool
thing because with them reaching this
point and the Phalanx arriving the
question was if we essentially put our
consciousness into a pure machine shell
as opposed to you know part human and
part machine
are you guys going to accept that and
the response of the of the the Phalanx
is now given when they say yes we find
this acceptable we find it acceptable
that because you were bred is a
combination between whatever your
biological race was which was human and
machinery being merged together as a
cyborg reaching its current form of
enlightenment you're not truly a machine
and we as the Phalanx only absorb like
machine base entities so put your
consciousness in a machine and you can
come hang out by us basically what it
comes down to and it works because as
soon as that happens the elders
basically eradicated by the by the
entirety or at least by this particular
phalanx force and when the question is
asked by the librarian when it's talking
to this future version of Nimrod why is
it the elder was destroyed nearby
basically responds by saying when it
comes to the Phalanx there's simply just
but one phase out there and this is
Hickman doing a huge amount of
world-building because what Hickman
basically says is that throughout the
entirety of the universe you have black
holes and where conventional wisdom
would tell us that black holes are just
giant gravity wells right collapsed dead
stars that suck in everything around it
including light and nothing gets in and
it just gets broken down on the atomic
level and then who the hell knows what
happened to the center of it because
it's all theoretical because nobody's
ever been there before what he actually
says here is that these black holes are
essentially collapsed dead civilizations
right like entire intellectual
civilizations whose entire overall
knowledge and experience and everything
just collapse in on itself basically it
got so smart it collapsed in on itself
and when that happened it basically
created a kind of fissure in space time
but each one is not really alone and
said it's part of a greater whole
and this greater whole is this giant
series of networks and so essentially
every single black hole in the universe
is one part of this giant collective
consciousness and so because of that
like it's all networked and the the the
failings in turn come under that you
know and it and it's a cool concept
because what it basically means is that
it's it's literally the universe's own
intelligence more or less is a cool
thing because what this means is that
this kind of higher-level thinking that
it starts out that if you really kind of
piece these things together this is why
Jonathan Hickman is such an amazing
writer
if you piece these things together what
you
half our baseline sentinels from
baseline signals you go to mother or you
go to master mold from master molds you
go to mother mold from mother molds you
go to like actual like Omega signals
right so basically a blending between
human and machine from there you go on
to a higher level which is the Nimrod
and then from the Nimrod you go on to
yet even higher levels if they get high
enough they achieve like that I'm sorry
they achieve a late a state of
enlightenment they end up getting to
their current form and then then from
there they merged with the Phalanx and
emerging where the families goes on to
become even an even bigger part of an
empire which the families themselves
serve this absolute intelligence across
the universe it's an awesome sort of
introduction right because you know
hickman really breaks this down you've
got the technarch you've got the world
mind you got the Phalanx you've got
Titans you've got you've got the the
stronghold and then you've got a
Dominion right so kind of going from
like the baseline and then building it
all the way back up here there are
multiple threats right there are
multiple concepts they're really all
kind of seem to lead to this final level
of super intelligence it's a cool
concept I'm digging it but I'm really
loving what it is that Hickman's doing
but with that being said guys we're
gonna read this video to an end if you
are new here - comments explained make
sure you guys are the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]